[Music]
thank you all for joining us tonight um
so in Reading up a little bit on the
film I saw Ted that uh you were kind of
Roger's first meeting about this and so
I wonder was this project an instant yes
for all of you why or why not like what
was the thought process in hearing this
story and coming on to
work on it I think someone would have to
be a total fool to pass on this project
that Roger had already made the
documentary it was such a phenomenal
character um you could see it as a movie
right from the beginning it was just
like is the world ready for this film
and you know so many pieces have to come
together he said in that meeting he had
one act actor in mind and I'm not going
to reveal anything but that actor is on
the stage
today um but
uh yeah it was then just a question we
were really lucky too um out in the
wings is one of the Amazon Executives
Brianna o who also was a real believer
in the project from the very beginning
and it was a trick to figure out how to
get it made because um again frankly
credit where credit is due if guel
didn't have the courage the commitment
the tenacity the perseverance the kind
of I can get it done sort of thing
because you know I come out of indie
film where we know how to make it cheap
and I wanted to make it for $30 million
that's what I thought the the film
needed to be made at and uh eventually
we got down to
15 Amazon was in for
half we couldn't find a partner and guel
came to me at a meeting and said Ted
stop around make this movie
bring it to Mexico we can do it for half
that amount of money yeah we couldn't do
it for half that amount of money and he
knew that but we got we got to the point
where we could uh get there and guel
came on as a producer you know then to
do it really you know put his name and
everything on the line and uh we came
down to Mexico to make the movie
yeah gule were you always bringing that
energy or was this kind of like a longer
process even thinking about playing Saul
no yeah for me I mean it's
um I guess it started like every I mean
every film has its own journey and and
uh and its own story but uh this began
Er When Roger in a very candid
conversation in a in a a hotel he said
uh man like I want to do a film about
cassandro and at that point it was a
very like very far away sort of wishful
thinking you know and and um and little
by little all the pieces started to come
together and uh and in those moments
also there's the ups and downs there's
the kind of like okay it's happening no
it's not happening and then a lot of
people started to come together as well
to be part of the film ER and some of
them are here and uh and all of a sudden
the the film started to to Amal gal into
a into a reality but uh but really I
mean it's it's I think uh in Sundance
when the film came out that we realized
okay we managed to to make it you know
because there's always the risk of
things falling apart no ER it's always a
I mean it's an Act of Faith to make a
film no and but I I got very excited
from the beginning as soon as uh as
Roger told me about it like got got
excited about the story of of about
Cassandra because I I grew up watching
Lucha Li a big fan of Lucha Libre you
know as a kid and uh and cassandro was
um you know he was a character that came
afterwards you know no from my no he
wasn't in my generation he was like a
little bit afterwards and the and I
remembered him you know but the exotical
the whole world you know there was
something there that was so it got to me
you know it got to me and I started to
think think about it and and they
couldn't stop thinking about this
possibility and then when it started to
happen it was it was great because
finally I was going to I was going to
jump off the third rope you know and
play and play as a as a kid you know
what I always wanted to to do you know
yeah uh Mar Stella when you hear uh
Lucha Libre project are you like yes I'm
in or are you like oh that's a
challenge both yes I'm in and it is and
it was a challenge
very interesting and and so thrilled to
to learn the way these um outfits are
done from scratch in a very non-orthodox
way by the all the outfits that you see
on the film were done and especially for
the film and besides you know my
seamsters doing Cassandra outfits the
rest were done by the actual makers of
these type of uh they don't call them
costumes they call them equipments and
and um and it's real strange because
these guys and and you know they're
mainly men do not answer to patterns or
to um respond to any drawings you have
to tell them what you want so you talk
about the costumes and then you trust
them so it was a you know was a handful
but it was wonderful yeah face from so I
keep thinking we left all this money on
the table you know you all would have
bought those costumes that equipment if
we had sold them during Halloween you
all wanted to be cassandro too I know I
did
absolutely uh Marcelo I think the cool
thing with the film too is that it
really serves the story and the nuances
of it it's not just what ever we have in
our head of a l Lucha Liber movie and so
what were you thinking about initially
when you were thinking of coming on well
um what I really loved about I mean of
course gel and the performance and and
my admiration for for his work previous
and but particularly in this film is it
was so incredible to see that and be a
part of it and I really love Roger uh
our director comes from documentaries
and he really this is his first
narrative film and I love the grit of it
and also how inspiring it is I mean it
would have been uh a different director
a different movie might have been all
sort of dark and all great or all
inspiring and kind of syrupy and he was
able to find this balance between the
light and the Darkness of the character
and ultimately it's an extremely
emotional very inspiring story and and
it was a canvas that you know I had
never had a chance to work on this world
is so it's like a magical world it's so
different but um it's so dramatic um and
I just uh
talk to Roger a lot about the fights and
there's kind of almost like this movie
within the movie each fight is a little
story that keeps and folding and and how
we got the score to my first instincts
were to just go like 100% right away and
Roger was very very good at like pulling
back and say hold on you know he's not
Cassandra yet let's let's take our time
and and we we had a very we were very u
in sync about what the music needed to
be we talked a lot about the trumpet and
how that was the instrument that could
really uh portray both sort of the
subtle and and introspective part of
Cassandra's life of sa's life and the
the love story but then as he becomes
cassandro the trumpet can also really
open up and become this very heroic um
um instrument and give this sound so um
but it was just a very fortunate um
Meeting of Minds and also I had worked
had the luck of Tad hope here gave BAS
Bally gave me a career many many years
ago uh when we worked on ding the floor
and our editor aono gonz is also a very
old collaborator and Todd black he
worked in that movie too these two had
yeah we we have our little Brazilian
Mafia kind of thing going on the side
and and Todd black also one of the
producers I had worked with many times
so it was like a lot of people from from
different uh parts of walks of life but
mostly I just love the story and I just
was just complet completely enamored
with the performance and with this and
what what gu did with his character yeah
absolutely I think speaking to that K uh
I wonder if there's a little uh art
imitating life did it feel at all when
you were more so becoming cassandro did
you feel that confidence and sort of
like a new kind of power and uh
embodying the show shower aspects of
souls
transformation yeah we I mean something
that I've been thinking a lot about the
the character is that I mean
cassandro you know Saul invents
cassandro or plays a character in order
to find himself in order to play with
that kind of um that mythology that he's
trying to deconstruct the father no in a
way cassandro is is that pathway towards
that and uh and me that's something I do
as an actor a lot and I also sublimate
many personal things of course when I'm
interpreting a character and um and
there's always an opportunity with all
the characters to actually come up with
something that has to do with myself you
know or my life you know and and um and
my Curiosities as well you know my my it
is the joy of acting that uh thankfully
I've been I've been able to kind of uh
um you know be being able to live that
that that that Joy you know and and uh
and nurture from it h so yes there was
something very um special I think it the
the the most ratat moment happened when
um I was uh in front of El Santo um
having to wrestle against Santo you know
that was like okay man I I used to
play you know playing his father and as
a kid and now I'm wrestling with the son
of El Santo the inheritor of the Mask
you know the the son of the legend and I
have to you know and and and he's also
very he was very kind and very very warm
as well as all the other luchadores and
the organization the tri fantastic
organization and and um and he was very
um he sorry I'm I'm trying to speak in
from Spanish to English translating
immediately but like uh he was very good
at kind
of
he was saying like man you're you're
really good like you got you got it and
and I was like oh my God don't tell me
this like you know yeah yeah very very
excited and and that moment was
incredible when we shot that uh that
that scene of the of the fight the Lucha
against the El Santo it was incredible
because it was a script that we all knew
like we all started to shout Santo Santo
Santo and man the the the you know the
it just starts to get incredible the
whole thing I I it really it was amazing
it was really really beautiful to be
able to play that as an adult you know
as a 40-year-old guy you know like it
was really really wonderful yeah and C
can I just touch on that because it it I
think so much of what G just said there
talks about the whole film making
process that when we were developing the
script that that question of who wears
the mask when he's wearing a mask what
mask is it was like a big theme that was
running through it and of course the
exoticos are the one character that
doesn't wear a mask but you know you
know not physically yeah well could wear
a mask yeah yeah there's no rules we
yeah we well that one of the things we
were getting wrong then in the
development process but but also like so
much of it like when you're starting
build a team and trying to move
something through a corporate
Enterprise on one hand you feel like
well we have to put on the airs that
we're going to get this made in order to
get it made but are we ever going to
really get it made we're doubting
ourselves at the same time and
um that it it is also then we were very
aware that within the Changing Times of
of streaming
yeah of when the movie first started
happening there was this huge
opportunity to start to tell stories
from a different perspective with
different characters than what most of
the kind of Hollywood
American you know Studio complex was and
we had this great opportunity but would
we ever really get to do it and if we
got to do it were we capable of doing it
right and who are the right partners and
how do you do that and what one of the
things when we were down there making
it gel not only had the weight of uh the
role not only the weight of being a
producer on the movie but everyone that
was on that set was there because of him
because because we were shooting it in
Mexico I didn't know these people you
know I didn't know they weren't there
because of me and they weren't there
because of Roger so so gu had this extra
weight like the character cassandro who
has this growing community and weight
and people he has to also start to
realize he's performing for and changing
their lives you and then once you're
reaching at the end you know we believed
we had a beautiful movie but you really
don't know you have a beautiful movie
you're trying to find the ways to get to
it you need every little piece and
you're kind of willing it and you're
kind of bullshitting right and you
praying that it's all going to come
together but precisely that moment that
GA mentioned in the beginning like when
you get to Sundance and you see the
people of the movie and you see how itff
affected sa who was there and that it
was all worth it it feels so much like
that same sort of thing of yeah we all
were finally getting to you know wrestle
with the hero or the son of the hero
that we wanted we finally got to get
this movie out it just felt like it was
a metaphor to me so I had it no no
totally I think it hits on something
that I was wondering about is that uh a
great thing we've sort of finally been
realizing is that you can find
universality and uh specificity and so I
want to sort of going down the line uh
as this project evolved was there
anything that you find wanting to
highlight in it becoming more Mexican or
more Latino uh Marcelo um Rogers
directions was he wanted more the idea
of Mexico than being like explicitly
Mexican um it was a more like we talked
a lot about any moricone scores for
spaghetti westerns for instance which
were you know not really American or
there were Italians doing stories that
were you know
where T took place in Mexico and they
but it was just the idea of it and so it
was a more impressionistic idea and we
talked a lot about jazz and because of
the trumpet and and Noir score so he
wanted to kind of have the flavor of it
but he wanted to be very sophisticated
we used he wanted to be gritty we used a
lot of distorted kind of organs and
things that didn't feel out of place but
he never wanted it to be oh no we want
it to be as you know it has to sound
very much of a particular time and and
or a particular place it was more
evoking so there was a lot of freedom in
that which I loved and and it was very
much an idea of a hybrid it's also a
border story so I feel like it's you are
dealing with both sides of this and for
me as I'm Brazilian but um I'm Latin and
you know we consider ourselves Latinos
and and it's just so wonderful to be
able to tell like Ted was saying the
stories from other points of view now
and and and and it's so Universal and
like by the time you get to the end
when the kid is is talking to to
cassandro and you know and it just feels
like a kid could be in Japan and have
the same experience and I think Roger
really wanted to deal with the universal
aspect of the story and how can this
transcend and I've seen how people
Americans Europeans and people from
everywhere have seen this movie are very
moved by it and I think that was what we
were going for with the music and I I
imagine beyond the music too
well for me it was trying to make it you
know as more realistic as possible
because it is a border story and for me
it was so important to portray the
border with all of its American
influence and basically you can tell in
in gu his performance and everything his
accent his look Cassandra was that way
you know he was very much um I think
influenced by fashion of the two world
so feel Mexico but basically in the mom
in the mom you know mom is really really
a portray of what I understand women up
in the north of Mexico are and it's so
important for her you know to be all
these carrying this wonderful animal
prints which serve as as a as an uh
inspiration for for cassandro you know
to to to come out finally so it was just
really trying to be very authentic there
isn't much information like for her you
know we had information about cassandro
and his stage Persona and few pictures
here and there of his everyday life once
he starts being very famous and starts
traveling you can tell in his everyday
clothes that there's also a lot of
influence he likeed Prince as well as
his mom so I tried just to be as as as
you know to do justice to his story so
not coming out because we always said
it's not a coming out story but true to
his um shine and freedom all the time
and um that's it very
meic and then you're in New Territory
Ted and well it the whole process for me
really reminded me a lot of my initial
work with Ang Lee um on Bo both uh his
first feature and then the second one
Wedding Banquet not just because of the
gay themes there
but also uh he was working in a culture
that he was still a little alien felt a
little alien to Roger wasn't from Mexico
um he needed to depend on a lot of his
collaborators to to get it um but that
that adage that you started this the
specific is the universal I think was
very much key with those films Wedding
Banquet and pushing hands being able to
break through to the degree that they
they did and what I had done with him
and then what uh Roger and I and David
Teague the the co-writer on the script
had done a lot of in the early
development was try to make it specific
and personal for David and Roger where
there was something in like they often
said like the first half of the story is
I can't remember who's first had the
half one half was David one half was
Roger and they really wanted to to find
those things the relationship with the
mother the the the pieces of her
clothing things that that summoned the
personal for them on it and to try to
keep it keep a emotional truth so that
level of authent authenticity was what I
was trying to help police initially
because I didn't expect my time was
going to go much further than the script
but as luck would have it I got to spend
a lot of time on set yeah and then GLE I
feel like there's so many levels both uh
acting and producing and really knowing
this world first as a fan and now
embodying this uh character this real
life person and so what were kind of
those small details that ended up kind
of meaning the world to you and
embodying uh so or Cassandra I mean
first it's a it's a film that we did
with uh with our family no with our
filmic family and the and uh that was
great because that's what pulled through
the film that's what made it happen and
uh
and there was also a kind of um uh you
know everyone's kind of um motivation
was also uh in love with the story of
Cassandra but also with a c curiosity of
the border and what that represents
because it's not is the border is not uh
Mexican or is not from the United States
like it's a culture of its own and uh
and we wanted to to be aware of what
goes on there and uh I've always been H
fascinated by it I I have I have no
family members from from the border but
H but it is a place that is full of
strange H and beautiful H and culture
that is an amalgam of different cultures
and but it's a it consists of coming and
going and also of constantly ignoring
the the horrendous wall that exists
there the stupid wall that exists there
you know and you have to ignore it
because it's if not it's impossible to
to live um people grow up with a with a
that wall in front of their houses and
um and it's it's something you have to
kind of you know ignore and and that's
something that I I wanted to also play
in this in this uh in this film because
it is about that also Saul comes and
goes Saul goes and changes to another
person where he crosses the Border he
has to play for society he has to play
another character you know when when he
he has to behave well in the United
States you know he cannot be the because
if not he goes to prison you know has to
be like a kind of like it's a you know
we wanted to to to um to explore that
and to really really nurture a kind of a
a film about a border no about the the
border and uh and about the dualities
that uh that we all live with and that
we have to uh H go through in life no in
a way ER but yeah that that to mention
just a a few things because there were
so many you know so so many things and
examples that kind of um made it made it
really really beautiful I mean now now
for example I I realize that um I mean
I've been saying this in all these q&as
because it's a it's something that just
came up to me you know like after
watching the film is that uh ER you know
the it's it's society that comes out of
the closet
like we we were really not wanting to do
a a film about we wanted to do what
happens after no not like the coming out
no but then looking at the movie I was
like oh man it's society that comes out
Clos no all of a sudden Society is like
okay with like let's let's support
cassandro yes it's fine of course and uh
and that's a change that happened and uh
Lucha Li is a is a sport highly skilled
very difficult very complicated very
hard you have to have a huge physical
condition you know you have to be like
in top shape because it's really really
it's a mix of Judo and GRE or Roman
wrestling and acrobasis and Theater and
like everything no you have to give a
spectacle you have to give a show H it's
a bit like salsa you know for those
those of you might think like oh
everything's arranged and everything it
is not it is like you have to to to get
to know the codes of what goes on you
know in for you to improvise as well
because you're improvising all the time
you know like when people dance salsa no
that's that's what happens and um and
Lucha Li is one of the few sports that
has ER that you know openly
gay athletes competing ER you know
there's not many especi especially when
there's money involved there's not not
not many gay athletes going there know
like football or other sports no um I
mean well at least out of the closet no
uh yeah come on statistically it has to
be no so so it's a it's uh yeah it's a
it it was very great to to fall into the
world of Lucha you know and play with
that with with all its complexities and
and its details yeah yeah no I think
that's why stories like these are
amazing to see on screen because often
we kind of forget that there's a lot of
first that already happen we keep
thinking that like oh this is kind of a
new breakthrough and it's like no like
give people more credit we can we were
cool about this years earlier um but you
were hitting on something that I was
interested in the we talk a lot about
cassandro the showman but you he is also
an athlete so what was the work in doing
that and I wonder sort of was were you
all in your work at all sort of
sports-minded or think thinking about
this as a sports film as well so first I
want to hear your work and then um I did
I mean for basically for the training H
I'm going to come up with a video for
everyone to to to do it it's very easy
it's a at the beginning because it's uh
eating a
lot and doing a lot of exercise like a
lot you know but doing mainly not
weights but just you know calisthenics
and kind of like you know getting strong
getting really really strong and then
the the the difficult but fun part comes
when I like two months before starting
to shoot I started to train wrestling no
with uh with Tria this organization that
is incredible is one of the biggest
organizations of Lucha Liber in the
world and uh and they they were really
kind they were very generous and
Chessman and Tano Jr my my my mentors my
my trainers they included me and and
Roberto colindres who plays uh Sabrina
they included Us in the in the world of
uh the upand cominging wrestlers ER for
their training and uh and that was
fantastic because these guys are
amazingly good at what they do and we
had to warm up and live you know like do
the the workout that they do you know
and uh and it is pretty hard it's really
really complicated it hurts a lot you
have to learn how to fall for example
you have to learn how to fly you have to
learn how to many things you know walk
the ropes You Know da da da and you have
to also know that you're doing a
spectacle that you're giving a good show
as well you know so that has to it's
it's fantastic it's it's it's a great
it's a great sport it's very difficult
to practice it yeah H but as a kid I
used to practice it you know when I was
a kid I mean I used to you know with my
friends I used to kind of make you know
the the okay now you go down and we
would sometimes you know when one was
supposed to go down and the other one
was supposed to jump we would both jump
at the same time and like it would be
like a huge you know yeah but um yeah
and that happen still as an
adult but yeah yeah it was it was great
to to to do also a very joyful side of
the of the sport as well because uh I
don't know why wrestling has been seen
as has been considered like a sort of a
trashy sport you know a kind of a thing
and no no no no these guys are are
incredibly incredibly strong and and and
very dedicated and you have to be very
healthy as well in order to be able to
do it yeah and to see the effect that it
has on the crowds too where it's almost
like a church these people are going to
see the wrestlers it's really something
to see uh I we probably have like two
seconds but I guess if you guys had
anything uh to add on the sports aspect
of this I'd love to hear it I I I think
what was wonderful is the way the
discipline and how guile threw himself
to the character which allowed me to you
know put over sometimes over just the
really enduring hard fittings and the
physicality of the of the sport you know
and going through you know really heavy
coats that look like you know like a
cave that are so light and they're not
they're heavy and he would take them off
on stage you know on the ring and you
know looks like a feather and he was
just like there you know and I had to
sort of take in consideration that in
some part but it was mainly that he
became very strong and disciplined and
we had to do a little sacrifice no there
sorry sorry to interrupt but we had to
do a little sacrifice there because at
the beginning obviously when when
Cassandra is like a beginning to to you
know to become cassandro um he makes the
the costume out of his his mother's um
blouse yeah exactly the blouse and also
the hot pants I
know and I don't recommend wrestling
with Hot Pants no it's the only thing I
I can tell that it's it's not like that
yeah we can tell that Cassandra was
learning at that point because yeah it
was like okay she had to endure you had
to endure a lot it's only going to be
this time never again hot pants for this
afterwards it's leotards you know it's
that kind of like the body no like yeah
but they were you know Jean
and stretchy stretchy jeans at that time
it was like iter less engineer Den him
so it was tough on him it was tough very
tough very strong it helped you it
helped exactly yeah it's a very very
difficult sport it's it requires a lot
from you physically and you know just to
do it all that shine and sequins and
embroidery and make it look so
easy only him
yeah I didn't think we were going to end
on hot pants but I kind of love it um
all together hot pants one two three hot
pants oh my God thank you so much guys
thank you Marcelo Mar uh Ted and
guel oh my God and tell your friend
[Music]
cassandro